hello everyone how's everybody doing I
hope you're doing fine
hope coronavirus is keeping you at home
so that you don't get sick or hurt I
mean by the police so ya better stay at
home you know it's gonna be compulsory
pretty soon it's gonna be part of our
daily lives maybe hopefully we all get
back to our regular business I'm not
sure that's gonna happen like regular I
don't know there's gonna be a lot of
people unemployed who knows what's
coming up riots
strikes more violence robberies crime in
general who knows I guess it's going to
be interesting the next few months for
those of you who are interested I do
have in the description a couple of
articles that I published some years ago
I've been peddling for the last 20 years
that we are the last generation of
humans on earth doesn't mean you're
going to believe my theory the purpose
is to understand it get a different
perspective you may not agree fine but
it's good to get a different view that
you won't see out there in mainstream ok
this channel in general has totally
different views on just about everything
from the extinction of Neanderthal to
the Dinos to to space-time and quantum
mechanics and strength theory the whole
works science is really in bad shape and
one of the reasons it's in bad shape
I'll tell you why it's that for the last
400 years we have not been doing science
the 17th century so-called scientific
revolution took us on the wrong path it
took us on the path of mathematic
and took us on the path of doing
experiments to develop technology and
people confuse those two disciplines or
activities with what physics is supposed
to or science is supposed to be about
which is about explaining phenomena you
need to explain a mechanism and what we
don't have today is no not one rational
explanation one rational mechanism
illustrate able that you can illustrate
there directly right for how especially
the invisible mechanisms of mother
nature work like you know gravity
magnetism electricity light so on so
yeah you you can see the two articles I
got a couple articles and one informal
article in the description there I won't
deal with that today I'm gonna deal with
something else today I'm going to deal
with dimensions dimensions what are
dimensions well it depends on who you
ask I guess if you're gonna ask a
mathematician you're gonna get one
answer if you're gonna ask a rational
human being you're gonna get another
that's more or less how it goes okay
here's the main points that I want to
make today okay let's run through them
real quickly the dimensions of math have
nothing to do with the dimensions of
physics math has some weird dimensions
or notions of dimensions and physics
rational physics at least has you know
very simple very baby like notions of
dimensions and so so hard so difficult
that it's just length width and height
that's it
we have length width and height and math
no you need to take like ten courses at
the university to know what a dimension
is and you still come out without
knowing ok math I mentions have to do
with measurement and magnitudes ok and
they don't have to do with what the
dimensions of
physics are which are direction and
orthogonality perpendicularity okay
physical dimensions are strictly
qualitative because of that in math
anything is and can be a dimension
that's why they talk about infinite
dimensions because you can you know they
have so many temperatures of dimension
mass is a dimension you know shoes were
to buy shoes that's what I mentioned
everything that I mentioned in
mathematics so that's why they talk
about infinite dimensions hopefully
they're not implying that all these
dimensions are nested one inside the
other and that we live in
nested universes you know three
dimensional here for above it fit five
above that and so on down the line you
know that that just means that you're
trying to get rid of the question you're
saying you're not gonna answer that
question because we don't know that's
the answer there that infinite
dimensions gives you yeah
math dimensions are actually number
lines and what these people have done is
use the word dimension in in the context
of math for magnitudes and they refer to
them as you know that mentions or
coordinates or vectors when they have
nothing at all to do with that mentions
coordinate support vectors especially of
those of physics but it wouldn't matter
anyways because if if they're gonna make
no distinction like the next number on
the list their math no distinction
between dimension coordinated vector
there is no this in fact dine mentions
are defined in terms of coordinates what
are coordinates just numbers and so what
these people are talking about number
lines and I don't know why they call
them that mentions but but they cross
the line into physics when they try to
give you a physical interpretation and
they tell you stuff like you know
space-time is four-dimensional what do
they mean like that are they
extrapolating what we understand
normally by three-dimensional to four
dimensions is that what they're saying
that here we have a three or rot
or a house that is three-dimensional
right and now we have some other thing
unimaginable unusual izybelle
out there that is four dimensional
they're using that as as a they're
extrapolating that notion of three
dimensions of the four dimensional when
they say that and and so the question is
you know is is there something called
four dimensional out there you know an
object and when you find out that the
fourth dimension is time according to
the mathematicians right and yeah you
have a serious problem
visualizing that object because there is
no such monster that is four dimensional
yeah it's just a lot of word wizardry
that's what it is that's what it amounts
to math invented the curved dimension
you know you have length width and
height right in physics and they have
two properties they have Direction each
one of those has direction and they have
orthogonality they have perpendicularity
one with respect to the other two there
is no such thing or notion as length
without width and height and vice versa
you can't have height without within
blank and so on okay you need you need
those because it has two properties when
its direction and the other one is
perpendicularity and the question is
whether you can bend direction I mean as
far as I know directions is always
straight you point straight you know
wherever Direction is and these people
are making curved dimensions they're
curbing the dimensions around the
spheres or whatever unbelievable and you
know you had a couple of geniuses in the
19th century one was Lobachevsky and the
Russian guy and another one was was the
name riemann and they curved the
triangles again they were using curved
dimensions you know Kurt
I don't know what that is I have no idea
what a curved triangle is so yeah they
modified the language a lot to
accommodate all these notions okay and
they ended up with irrational language
primarily three words one of them is
space the word space is just outrageous
the notions they have in mathematics
okay and as long as they keep them there
in the asylum no problem
the problem is they extrapolate there or
try to bring those into physics into
science that's where we have a problem a
lot of they keep it in the mental asylum
we have no problem they can call it
whatever they want on space and so they
talk about space and they equate it with
solids many a time because that's one of
the synonyms of space dimension itself
dimension of coordinates and vectors
completely irrational language that they
have created in fact we're gonna go
through a list of some of the notions or
the concepts that they've developed for
dimensions and you're gonna see that
it's just mind-boggling not
mind-boggling in the sense of oh I got
to study this now in the sense that it
should all be thrown away in the garbage
can we have no need for this nonsense
okay and what all the shows in the end
is that math is not the language of
physics okay a lot of them a lot of
people doubt it is saying oh yeah math
is the language of physics no the
language of physics is illustration you
have to be able to illustrate a
mechanism so that people can watch the
movie with all your illustrations
they're in motion and understand the
mechanism what mechanisms especially the
invisible mechanisms we want to see
magnetism we want to see gravity we want
to see how light works we want to see
how electricity works how the atom works
all the invisible stuff that's what they
need to do we know all the visible stuff
you know but the invisible stuff that
they that we have no rational
explanations from the establishment from
the mathematical establishment today why
because they say that math
and not illustration is the language of
physics that's where we have the problem
that's where the problem originates and
unfortunate it's these people who have
taken over so-called science physics
they run the journals and from the
journals you know you have all these
blogs and people who more or less
translate that scientific language as
they call it for the masses so that they
can get a glimpse in general what these
guys are thinking or doing out there you
know it's just uh and and it's and it's
all the same group in other words what
you have is people who have blogs and
and more informal magazines and they
take the published papers and they
translate them so if you want to go in
there and you want to publish something
they won't let you unless you bring it
you play by their rules you have to play
with math yeah you have to introduce
math equations no pictures please
because they don't give a damn at all
about physical interpretations that's
why all their physical interpretations
are irrational and will always be
because they don't care about it and so
you know people want to ask you those
types of questions you want to know how
the universe runs and they'll never get
an answer from a quality a rational
answer from a qualitative point of view
they're only going to get some math
nonsense that they don't understand and
then the other fellow will say well you
know you should have studied math like I
did you know and then you would
understand and that's the answer that's
it that's the answer all the time ok so
what are the definitions of dimension
well here we have the definition for
mathematics branch known as mathematics
a language is mathematics the language
of physics of science well is it Chinese
or Greek the language of physics meaning
languages of language right what's
different between math
has these hieroglyphics there what's
different between that and Greek or I
don't Spanish okay
you tell me okay property of space
extension in a given direction that's
what a dimension is okay according to
the Wikipedia a straight line has one
dimension a parallelogram has two
dimensions and a parallelepiped has a
has three dimensions there you see them
one two and three
well I have a problem with the first one
now that number one you know that's a
line I'll make it a little I can't make
it bigger I'll make it bigger from he
only not for you but if you look at that
line you know you can see it and you can
see it it means that it's not one
dimension it's got two dimensions
it's got width and height so I don't
know if anyone could draw one
dimensional anything there is no such
monster no such object that is one
dimensional so that's why they call it's
an extension so it's an extension a
geometric figure okay because the other
two are figures no doubt about it
because the number two is
two-dimensional the third one is
three-dimensional no problem there
the problem is the first one you know
what is aligned is aligned on a
geometric figure and an object if it's
defined as one-dimensional if it's
defined as extension you know what are
we talking about what is that or is that
distance is that distance traveled
displacement maybe what is that and
until you you zero in on those key
questions on those key words that they
use you know these people are just
giving you work wizardry that's all
they're doing that's why they claim they
can't you find a point line or the plane
okay generalization of this property to
spaces with curvilinear extension spaces
spaces have extension I thought space
was nothing about space was vacuum
and this is the issue the issues that
use these words space they bring it in
there they're talking about space as
meaning geometric figures such as planes
and or categories of geometric figures
such as planes and solids they call them
spaces that's where we start getting a
little nebulous with the jargon okay as
the surface of a sphere so here they
have a curb dimension again you know I
don't know if you how you can curve
direction but if you can figure it out
please let me know okay the
generalization of this property to
vector spaces at the hilbert space okay
the generalization of this property to
fractals which can have dimensions that
are non integer real numbers who cares
who cares what you know what do you mean
dimensions that have real numbers what's
that what's that mention have to do with
real numbers and again you know anyone
dealing with fractals usually is you
know a little cuckoo in the head these
people are fascinated by these patterns
they see in nature I don't know the
snowflake may be the what is it the stem
of a plant you know they they look for
these patterns in they're fascinated by
them they call fractals they study them
to exhaustion and all that's nonsense we
don't need fractals on planet earth or
anywhere fractals are useless for almost
everything there there's nothing we can
do with fractal what's the point of
practice fractals is nonsense that's
what it is
and a lot of people are just absolutely
fascinated by those patterns they see I
guess they see information they're
mother nature's telling them something
okay and then the last extension in time
space-time has three dimensions of space
and one of time
okay whatever space-time is when you
look it up you always find that fishnet
there you know that's that's what you
always find then they take you tell you
not to take it
seriously not to take it literally well
I'm taking it literally because that's
what's in front of me that's why I take
it literally if you don't like that you
know
bring me space-time the real McCoy I
mean that's what they always put a
three-dimensional fishnet projected onto
a two-dimensional platform or background
and I'm not supposed to take that
literally what am I supposed to do what
am I supposed to interpret this here
they have the earth sitting on
space-time and on this fishnets so
ridiculous so ridiculous okay and here
we have mr. Stephen Hawking and what the
he died a couple years ago and what did
he say well he in his book he goes in
there and he has a spacetime diagram but
notice that he's uh he's got space as
the coordinates or as the dimensions or
as the vectors who knows what those are
space never saw never heard of a
dimension called space he is he the
issue is that he says the the
mathematicians say that length width and
height well that's not what they mean by
dimensions but then that's what they
show they show length width and height
they call lengthen with space they call
height time supposedly those are those
three are 90 degrees to each other so
they're depicting dimensions of physics
okay and that's what they want you to
understand that they're talking about
physics because they're gonna reach
conclusions physical interpretations
what they said which they always say
they proven yeah they're gonna shove it
down your throat as proof and what are
they show they show space and space and
in the elevation or height or who knows
what that is there they they have time
can you pit time against space does that
make sense
can you pit time against length and
width is time this time flow at 92
to lengthen with and again they put
arrows but lengthen with don't have
arrows
you know lengthen with our qualitative
lines you know parameters or whatever
you wanna call they don't grow and see
they put arrows like if they grow time
grows you the the arrow for time is okay
but for space whatever space is there's
no dimension called space but that's
what what he puts so yeah you got to
look at all this in in the proper
context what are they talking about are
they talking about math or are you
talking about length with the knight
which belongs to physics because we can
all understand length width and height
and that's three dimensional that's what
we call it you know a table is three
dimension of it has to reflect with an
eye the one that's sitting here you know
that's it's a three dimensional table no
problem there but these people are
talking with some about some abstraction
out there and then they hint or
insinuate through their drawings that
they're talking about the real world and
they're introducing length width and
height and and they're calling you a
space and time so what are we talking
about are we dying about space and time
whatever that is a time running
perpendicular to space is is that what
they're showing there you know it makes
no sense what these people are talking
about what they're illustrating and what
they later on say well don't take it
literally it's like you know what why
didn't I attend this this conference if
if I'm not supposed to take any of this
for real okay what are the dimensions of
physics according to the wise men of of
our days
hey and again this is from the wikipedia
says measurement in length width and
thickness thickness thickness is a
dimension again a lot of it to do with
that next were their magnitude size
matter has that mentioned a topology a
magnitude that serves to define the
location
of an element within a given set as I of
a point on a line an object in space or
an event in space-time well let's look
at these yeah here we have these okay
put them over here yeah there you have a
point on a line an object in space okay
or in a space and an event in space-time
which is that fishnet you see there you
know the kerbs fishnet to the three
dimensional fishnet projected onto two
dimension nothing there is four
dimensional at all
okay that's the space-time fishnet you
don't have to take my word for it you
can go on the Internet
just put the word space-time and you'll
always find this this ridiculous
fishnet that's what they show what is
that fish that's supposed to be what
gives shape to the fishnet you know
there's what's the white stuff in
between the the the fishnet there that
gives the fishnet some background what
is that white stuff is that thought I
mean you know these people put whatever
nonsense there and you're supposed to
look at that and say well don't take it
literally okay so what is it does any of
this have anything to do with physics I
mean here we have point on a line there
are no such things as points and lines
zero dimensional points in
one-dimensional lines in the real world
of physics there's no such thing as that
last one space-time fishnet
they can't illustrate it because they
cannot even imagine it so if we cannot
even imagine it are they talking about
the real world is the real world
unimaginable I mean as far as I know
when if from here on now to the end of
infinity wherever the last bit of matter
in the universe is it's all 3d you know
from earth outwards it's all 3d you can
just run three coordinates or three
dimensions if you want if you want to
look at the whole bit of matter if Ray's
the world the universe and just put
dimensions there to measure
all the matters in the in the universe
well you can only put three
perpendicular lines you can't put a
fourth perpendicular light to those
three it's just that simple
and that tells you that everything from
here on out is three-dimensional using
that that notion of that mention where
is this fourth dimension fifth dimension
or like in string theory you got ten and
twenty six dimensions just absolute
nonsense that has nothing to do with
reality okay and then then they fix it
by saying well they're tiny dimensions
that are currently queued around you
know hidden from our view yeah these
people deranged in their head you know
okay
another notion is the number of elements
in a finite basis of a given vector
space what is a vector space okay let's
see oh and here we have a number of
elements whoa how many elements do we
have there well we have a couple Indians
we have bows arrows I don't know maybe
ten elements I mean what does this have
to do with physics what they're saying
here is that you can add two magnitudes
those arrows represent magnitudes you
can add V plus W and get a third arrow
what is that third arrow is that an
engine arrow is that one of those darts
that some of these natives throw at you
now no those arrows are just numbers
magnitudes that's what they're showing
and so you know they depict them with
arrows and one things they're talking
about arrows but they're not they're
talking about numbers which somehow
they're trying to depict so that you can
get a visualization of what they're more
or less talking about so yeah lots of
problem with all that and then there was
uh let's see this one here then you have
this one the last one there what was it
any Oh any for physics any of a set of
basic kinds of quantity as mass length
and time is that what what a dimension
is mass length and time are
mentions well that's fine now let's see
here here I try to illustrate here's
mass length and time okay this mass
co-run perpendicular to time or length
the time run perpendicular to length of
mass I mean what are these dimensions
that they talk about they they use the
word dimension every two seconds
specially in relativity and this is what
they're talking about they're talking
about nonsense that you know doesn't fit
our notions of what three dimensional
nallett e means or what length width and
height means so if that's not what a
dimension means in mathematics what does
it mean well what do you mean when you
say mass is a dimension what do you mean
that when you say time is a dimension
how is time in any way similar to length
are we talking about distance traveled
are we talking about a length of a table
or we talking about three mutually
perpendicular directions known as length
width and height which are qualitative
100% qualitative you know so the issue
is that these people have lost track of
what they're talking about
especially as long as they keep it in
math no problem
the problem is when they bring it into
physics and try to tell you we did all
the mathematics here we got all the
equations we get all the numbers we got
all the measurements and and quantities
the the amounts the magnitudes and now
they're gonna extrapolate that and try
to give you a physical interpretation
for how this universe works can they
tell you how magnet attracts another no
they can't tell you that but what they
can tell you is what gravity is it's
warpage of time that's what it is
there's warping space and time both
space 9 the warp space-time that means
the warping time because they turn time
into a stick and now that you can bend
it or warp it or you know who knows what
that's what they're doing and of course
after that they say well you're not
supposed to take
the analogy literally of course you have
because I can't even imagine warping
time how am I supposed to even take you
literally there's nothing literal about
it it's all absolute nonsense to say
that gravity is the warping of time
that's if that's a mathematical
description they can keep it within math
don't bring any of that into physics
don't tell me that in physics in science
in the rational world that you're going
to work time okay this is this is when
it gets dangerous when they say well
time is a dimension we're going to bend
that dimension we're going to curve it
which is what you know they the first
few pictures there that I put show okay
okay
what's the formal definition of
dimension because really they have a
single math and fans for them is the
same thing and so they they have these
they try to give you an idea that
there's a little difference between
physics and math no physics and math use
this not use this notion of that mention
in both math fears by the way they use
this notion of dimension in their
so-called disciplines okay in physics
and mathematics the dimension of a
mathematical space what is it the
minimum number of coordinates needed to
specify any point within it okay so what
are we saying we're saying down at that
mentions a coordinate what is the
coordinate well we can see you when you
look up the word coordinate you won't
find the definition what you'll find is
coordinate system it's okay we go to
coordinate system and it gives you an
idea what a coordinate is okay so what
is it a coordinate system is a system
okay that uses one or more numbers or
coordinates so what is a coordinate
another number so what is the dimension
well and minimum number of coordinates
meaning a minimum number of numbers
that's that's the definition of a
dimension in mathematics and math is
okay it's the minimum number of numbers
number of numbers that's the definition
they have today is that what a what
three dimensional means that your your
you got three numbers you know maybe
should claim at the lottery or something
you don't know what does this have to do
with science what does this have to do
it with physics with anything okay and
what are they useful to uniquely
determine the position of the points or
other geometric elements on a manifold
such as Euclidean space we're gonna put
points on spaces on vacuum oh nothing
okay fine but the interesting thing is
the position of a point and point what
is a point was it's a position it's a
location that's what a the word point
means so we got the position of a
position and that I mentioned is a
number of numbers you figure it out you
see if you can use any of that for for
anything okay of course none of this
makes any sense you will not be able to
make sense from a geometric true
geometric in other words physical point
of perspective point of view okay if
they keep wanna keep all that nonsense
in math to keep it there please don't
bring it into physics but it's when they
try to bring into physics that's when we
run into trouble
because we cannot use these deranged
irrational ridiculous notions that
they've developed in mathematics we
cannot use them in physics for anything
nothing at all it's all total trash
right so that's the issue the issues
when they try to bring it over if they
want to use it math to do their their
Asylum stuff go ahead and use it I don't
care but don't bring it into physics
okay so let's see what we have here we
have a space because we need a
definition of say they use this word
space every two seconds what is space
well they say space again this is from
the wiki space is the boundless
three-dimensional extent space is an
extent whatever that is is that a
physical object I mean it says
three-dimensional why would they use the
adjective three-dimensional to qualify
extent are they saying this thingy
whatever they're talking about this
space
is growing or extending or pointing or
facing in three mutually perpendicular
directions is that what the
three-dimensional adjective there means
is that what it stands for
three-dimensional extent okay but then
there we have another word the boundless
are they saying spaces infinite it's a
physical object that is infinite in
extent it extends forever keep that in
mind okay in which objects and events
have relative position and direction
okay at least they got one direction you
have direction as part of it but they
forget or thaw reality they never
mentioned that the fact that length
width and height are 90 degrees to each
other they draw them that way or at
least they project them that way on to
two dimensions implying that it's there
all at 90 degrees to each other but then
they never use that they say other but
that's not what we mean by dine mentions
anyway dimensions are important stuff
like mass and time temperature yeah I
don't know if temperature runs at 90
degrees to time you know physical space
physical space oh there's a physical
space okay is often conceived in three
linear dimensions it is by whom by the
looneys at the asylum I mean what do you
mean physical space three linear
dimensions what is this what are they
talking about every word is is
irrational in this context with time to
be part of a boundless again boundless
whatever that means four-dimensional
continuum it's a continuum continuum
what could that mean that there's no
accidents no interruptions
is that what space-time is known as
space-time it continued what is it
continuum is that a physical law can you
bring a continuum to the conference so
we can see it put in the middle of the
of the room so that we know what a
continuum is so all you have is all
these concepts extents and Continuum's
that's what you're talking about that's
what space and space-time are
the concept of space is considered to be
blah blah blah of importance to an
understanding of the physical universe
the concept of space I mean these are
the question is face an object or a
concept the space have shape or not it's
a black or white issue
it's space a physical object if it is if
it's got dimensions as they say it's
read I mention oh please bring a space
to the conference next time I want you
to put it in the middle of the room so
that we can all see it from all sides
all around I want to see your
three-dimensional space
what the hell are they talking about
what do you mean a three-dimensional
space no spaces what's out there between
the Earth and the moon that's called
space it's known as vacuum it's nothing
that's what it is nothing nothing that
which has no shape something that which
has shaped nothing that which has no
shape Durant and him now we can use
these words consistently rationally
scientifically but to say that you know
space is 3-dimensional well just bring
it to the conference room we'll find out
if it is just prove it
they like to Provari they improve that
space is 3-dimensional you know I want
you to bring a bit of it you know
illustrate it and and then we'll know
it's read I mention you know if someone
says is your table three-dimensional say
yeah and can you prove it yeah and you
bring the table in you say see it's
three dimensions got length width and
height 90 degrees to each other what
you're done you've proved it by bringing
your table okay do the same thing with
space bring space and show me that three
dimensional it's got length width and
height because that's what three
dimensional means okay okay so what was
this other word bound and it's not
bounded or it's unbounded okay unbounded
it's the unbounded space what do they
mean by that well here unfortunately
have a Hawking Stephen Hawking and he's
going to tell us what no bounds means no
unbounded and the problem here has got
two notions one has to do with time and
in another part of his book he talks
about something totally different which
is incessant walkie
okay he says in the first one space-time
was finite but had no boundary finite no
boundary there's a ball you know it's
finite in a sense that you know it ends
here
right it's the discrete object and then
it's uh it's bounded so what does he
mean how can it have be finer but no
boundary this has boundary and finite
both how can you have you know there
seems to be a contradiction somewhere
how can you have something that is
finite and not have a boundary and he
says it had no beginning no moment of
creation which is I don't know what does
that have to do with finiteness and
boundary Ness okay that's one he says
the universe is not infinity in space
but neither does space have any boundary
okay no boundary for space and what are
you talking about gravity is so strong
as space is bent around unto itself
these guys are bending nothing I mean
before you bend space please bring it to
the conference room so we know what
you're talking about what is three that
what is this three dimensional space
that you're talking about that gravity
bends it around itself what are they
talking about what is this nonsense
what is this jargon this this language
that they develop making it rather like
the surface of the earth okay two
dimensional right I guess the surface
that's what they say is and if what
these traveling now you started my
travel T trying to prove that it's
infinite or unbounded right in a certain
direction on the surface of the earth
whatever comes up against an impassable
barrier or falls over the edge but
eventually comes back to where once
started so how does that relate to the
first one the first one he says had no
beginning the second one he's got a
different notion of what he means by
unbounded which is you know that you can
walk around the earth incessantly here
we have one fellow
you know he's walking around the earth
or running the ball at least you know
and he's walking incessantly okay is
that what unbounded means I mean that
ball there or that earth or whatever
that is that's bounded it's got a it's
finite it ends at that surface but
walking incessantly is not unbounded
he's not walking unbounded Li he's
walking incessantly you know Steven
Gorky you should learn language before
he can say some of these these things
that he says or that he said okay here
we have another mention from Stephen
Hawking regarding dimensions again and
these people are demented I think they
have they suffer from dementia that's
what that mention probably means in
mathematics the fourth I mentioned time
what that meant time is a dimension
thought it was a number line is finite
in extent okay but it is like a line
with two ends for boundaries okay so we
got a line it's got an end okay fine
a beginning and an end we shall see
later that when one combines general
relativity with the uncertainty
principle of quantum mechanics it is
possible for both space and time to be
finite without any edges or boundaries
because again they're talking about
stuff that has nothing to do with a word
boundary because anything that is finite
by definition has boundary what they're
talking about is not boundary but saying
that there's no you can run around in
circles come back to your starting point
you won't find a wall that's what
they're saying that's got nothing to do
with boundary so so the way they show
their unbounded universe finite but
unbounded universe is what word wizardry
but they're doing is confusing concepts
here they're confusing the words what
they mean the word unbounded it has
nothing to do with walking around ok I'm
bout it means the same thing as finite
if they want to use the correct word
should say the universe is finite and
you can walk around it incessantly
that's that's Tony difference got
nothing to do with whether the universe
has edges boundaries offense okay let's
keep the context in the right place okay
that's the problem
and he says more announces the idea that
one could go right around the universe
and end up where one start it makes good
science fiction but it doesn't have much
practical significance because it can be
shown that the universe would wreak
elapsed to zero size before one could
get round I don't even want to wait for
his proof I mean total absolute garbage
nonsense these and these guys are paid
big bucks to say this not idiocy they
are it's it's unbelievable these guys I
mean he died but there's a whole bunch
of other behind him that say the same
nonsense they get a lot of money for
Saint us idiocy so yeah I don't know you
should take it with a pinch of salt okay
but what's interesting is after they do
other fancy footwork they here you have
a couple of them one is Stephen Hawking
and the other one is Leo Susskind now
he's a professor at Stanford University
and what are these people say well they
say can't they can't imagine their own
contraption their own space-time and
here you have first one from Steven
Gorky he says it is often helpful to
think of the four coordinates of an
event as specifying its position in a
four dimensional space called space-time
okay it is impossible to imagine a four
dimensional space so if it's impossible
to imagine maybe maybe there is no such
thing
maybe that's why and what they do is
they go through this rigmarole which
you'll see next here where they try to
show you why we can't imagine it says I
can't say now close your eyes and view
in your head five dimensions because I
can't do it either
okay at least he could see it's that all
I can do is say take XY and Z and at V
and W eventually a person with this type
of mathematical background begins to
develop mathematical intuitions for
things in other words you get brain
okay you you start accepting stuff that
is unimaginable
you know like spirits and Heaven and
Hell you know okay mathematics they
don't need the same kind of
visualization so we're stuck needing
mathematics because evolution it blames
that on evolution then equip us to
visualize 11 dimensional space times so
the fault is of the monkeys who gave
birth to Leo Susskind yeah all these
forefathers that we had they didn't give
us the right tools we're still stuck in
three dimensions and these guys are
already at the 11th dimension I mean
what does the 11th dimension have to do
with reality this is all garbage
nonsense poppycock that is being taught
at the university level these people
should be executed for for saying such
nonsense it's garbage it's ridiculous
it's not even not even funny
anyways you know the day I showed and
here I'll read reinforce it this is the
difference between the definitions of
math and the definitions of physics in
physics the comments are straightforward
length with an eye everybody can
understand it's just three mutually
perpendicular directions that's
essentially what it is what a
coordinates well the first point is that
unlike dimensions that point outwards
that mentions point inwards towards an
object you need three sticks that are 90
degrees to each other to locate an
object in the universe you know
that's these are the only three possible
mutually perpendicular directions you
cannot imagine a fourth direction okay
now you point towards the edit the
object always vectors that has to do a
motion that with location or orientation
vectors are motion in three mutually
perpendicular directions in which an
object can move that's what vectors are
okay and stuff breadth and elevation
sometimes you'll find
these people confused length with breath
and they put latitude in there they mix
them all up because to them they're all
what number lines which is he on the
bottom that's what what these so-called
dimensions coordinates and vectors
really are as far as mathematics is
concerned they are number lines and
these people call these number lines you
know dimensions coordinates vectors they
use these terms which have nothing to do
with what they're doing they should call
more lumber lines but see if they call
them number lines then they can't say
that space-time is for number lined you
wouldn't understand that you do huh what
do you mean is for number line no no
it's four-dimensional I understand that
4d I just can't imagine it's like 3d but
14 right now it's for number line
they're talking about four number lines
that can converge upon an object to
establish the locations with magnets is
with numbers that's all they're talking
about and that's totally different than
what we say when we say that something
is three dimensional but they use the
adjective four dimensional to modify or
or you know qualify space-time so they
treat space-time first as a physical
object even though it's got the word
time in there because they've got to do
their their gravity their geometry Oh
metric gravity by bending space-time so
they have to turn it into a physical
object and then they say well you cannot
imagine but you need four dimensions one
of which is time to locate a point
within space-time so it's a circular
argument you need what is space-time
space-time is what you need four
dimensions to locate a point within
space stuff that's what space-time is so
it's a and again if they keep it within
the asylum the mathematical asylum no
problem they can all the patients there
can do whatever they want with that and
hopefully someone throws in some
coronavirus in there just gets rid of
all of them but don't bring it into
physics don't bring anything
and the coronavirus or or the dimensions
of math into physics they have no place
in physics in physics its length width
and height
kindergarten stuff we're done that's it
that's all we need dimensions for okay
and they're all qualitative we have
knows no nothing no necessity no need
for magnitudes okay because you cannot
explain anything by putting magnitudes
you're gonna explain the mechanism
you're not going to describe
mathematically that's why math is not
the language of physics okay there was
another issue and that's this issue of
curves
what is it curved well it turns out that
you know the curve via some curves are
straight unbelievable and that's how
they ended up with curved dimensions
because I guess you know it doesn't
matter to them well here's a couple
definitions curve an object similar to a
line okay which does not have to be
straight meaning that sometimes it can
be straight is that what they're
debating here sometimes dimensions can
be straight sometimes they can be curved
and that's what a curve is a curved
direction I guess okay a curve is the
image of a continuous function from an
integral to a topological space okay and
then dictionary.com says a continuously
bending line without angles that more or
less is the notion we have in physics
you know continuously bending line
that's what a curve is we never confuse
a curve with a straight line but these
people say well a curve can also be
straight because to them it's a function
so functions in equation it's a bunch of
variables and numbers that's what it
means to them and it has nothing to do
with what a curve is whether were
rational human being understands for the
word curve you know you asked anyone did
the car curve yeah he he went in a in a
curve that's why we call call it a curve
because he bends it warps if you see a
straight line you don't say that's curve
now you say it's a straight line
nobody confuses a straight line with a
curve except mathematicians and again
they can keep that nonsense within
mathematics just don't bring it into
physics in the real world mathematics
also a dictionary
calm a collection of points whose
coordinates are continuous functions
again of a single independent variable
yeah they're talking about function
they're talking about nonsense that has
nothing to do with the word curve gain
again they keep it in math by and just
keep it there don't bring it here there
are no fewer than three discs and I like
the this comes from wolfram mathworld
and what you see there says there are no
fewer than three distinct notions of
curve throughout mathematics so you can
see that they have all these definitions
what did one guy use this is one
definition nearly I uses another you
know and so we don't know what a curve
is because everybody's got his own
notion it's all at hoc when they need it
for this they say well here I'm gonna
say that a curve is this and yellow I
said no well for me curve is this other
thing and everybody's doing their own
little thing and here you have a there's
one for topology the other one is for
algebraic geometry and the other one for
analytic geometry so they have all these
notions of what a curve is not even
worth reading okay you know there was no
one knows in mathematics what a curve is
you gotta take him to kindergarten show
what a curve in you know you draw a
little curve line say that's a curve see
how simple it was all these years and
why is this a problem well here you have
one bozo his name was Arthur Eddington
and this guy supposedly proved that like
curves around the Sun thus verifying
confirming proving einstein's notion of
theory of general relativity of 1915
1916 and he said it's true look we
proved it we went out there we saw that
we could see light coming around the Sun
okay during an eclipse and there you
have the the notion you see there's a
started faraway and light goes around
the Sun supposedly because the Sun
weighs down this canvas known as
space-time which you're not supposed to
take literally right and it bends it and
it curves light so they said look
space-time bent light that's you
here this constantly they use that word
bent and one of the problems there is
that no we're not trying to bending
because if we're talking about a photon
a little ball okay we're talking about a
little ball discrete little ball that's
coming right or you in a little way
because they will say that a photon is
really a wave okay so are these waves
discrete where are they what does a
photon is it isn't a photon treat is a
discrete entity a little ball and if
it's a little ball then you cannot talk
about bending light about bending a
photon no you can say that it swerved
you can say that it deflected that would
be the word that you would use you would
not say you bent a ball you say that the
ball was deflected and these people are
talking about bent light as if there's a
Content continuity in light from the
star all the way to the earth and you're
bending it you're warping light why
because the weight of gravity is so so
heavy yes gravity pulls on unlike so
much that it bends light what is it
bending a beam array is that is that
what we're bending so again they have
all these [ __ ] notions that there
because they have contradictions they
have developed all of these the [ __ ]
ridiculous notion of what space is what
curve means what bent means what a
dimension is what court what a
coordinate is they have all these
incredible notions these this language
that they develop and unless you know
you really took a course in the
university you can't follow these guys
because you don't really know what
they're talking about in physical terms
but they claim to be talking in physical
terms they claim to be interpreting the
real world out there though the priests
of the modern world as I call the
mathematicians you know these people
tell you look we can tell you how this
universe worked but in order for you to
understand us you got to take a course
high level course at the University and
so they can't bring it down to you
because
you know they cannot illustrate it on
the board they said look here's the
equation know the numbers and the only
way you're going to understand that if
you take of course and when you take the
course you still want to understand
because you can't explain it in normal
terms you can only talk it through
another Mathemagician and they they say
well yeah I understand what you're
saying
and what are they doing descriptions all
they're doing is descriptions that's all
that math can do well anyways I Arthur
Eddington did prove squat ok and here it
is you'll find in in the Wikipedia
you'll find tests of general relativity
supposedly all these tests have proven
general relativity it's the evidence for
the theory ok observational evidence for
the theory and you'll see several of
them there no no let there be no doubt
no one proves anything in science in
physics ok no one proves anything in
there proof means that they convinced
you you drank the kool-aid
that's what proof means there is no such
thing as proven science proof belongs
strictly to religion means you were
convinced you know and no one's going to
convince you otherwise that such as such
as true because they proved it to you
you were you convinced yourself that
it's true proof is not part of science
science we don't prove in science we
explain the mechanism objectively so
that you understand it then everybody
knows his own ways and reaches his own
conclusions that's the way it's done in
science when someone talks about
evidence and proof that they observed
and now they can prove and now that
they've verified they're talking
religion and especially when you know
they can't put it in normal terms if
they're not going to use the words
consistently because they have 10 20 30
100 definitions for each word you know
all kinds of things mentions we don't we
don't know what a damn mention is and
they say it's just a bunch of numbers
well if it's a bunch of numbers why do
you call it a 9/10 mention call it a
number call it a magnet to call it an
amount you know quantity whatever you
want to call it but they'll call it I
mentioned I mentioned is very clear what
it is select with a knight because
that's what the notion of three
dimensionality
so it's it's the language that's been
contorted and a big problem again is
when they extrapolate that language into
physics okay with that
we'll see you next time around we're
gonna continue on geometry I want to
make sure we cover just about every base
we can with geometry before we let go so
we'll see you then and take care bye bye